over watches Summer Games update is
celebrating the 2016 olympics in rio in
style and you can unlock tons of new
skin sprays voice lines victory poses
and player icons but unlike other items
these new additions cannot be purchased
with in-game currency they're only
available in the special summer games
loot boxes what's up with that game
director Jeff Kaplan explained saying we
want these items to feel extra special
and very rare so we don't want everyone
running around all the time in every
single summer games item we want this to
be a thing where six months from now you
look back on somebody using that cool
zaria skin and go oh man I can't wait
until next year when Summer Games
happens maybe I'll get lucky enough to
get that skin / watches Summer Games
event runs through August 22nd on all
platforms there are some great items to
grab like track and field tracer and
gold metal victory poses let us know
what cool stuff you've unlocked and for
everything you need to know about future
themed overwatch events stay grouped up
with gamespot
you